Doctor Strange is a very specific kind of
superhero.
Instead of patrolling the city for muggers
or bank robbers, he fights demons and warlords
from other dimensions and deals with the manifestations
of otherwise abstract concepts, like Eternity
and Death.
But while his bizarre, mind-bending adventures
have made him one of the weirder characters
in the Marvel Universe, the good Doctor has
left huge footprints on the cultural landscape.
From Steve Ditko’s psychedelic extra-dimensional
landscapes to his numerous connections to
the world of rock ‘n’ roll, here’s the
truth behind Dr. Stephen Strange.
Who wants to live forever?
In 1974's Doctor Strange #4, the sorcerer
battles Death.
Literally.
Inside the Orb of Agamotto, Doctor Strange
is confronted with the character Death, the
same skeletal woman whose tender affections
have always been craved by Thanos.
Strange fights hard to free himself, but ultimately
recalls the Ancient One's teachings about
how death is just another part of life.
After letting Death overcome him, he awakens
to find that this was merely the first in
a series of trials that he must confront as
the Sorcerer Supreme.
As a result of his surrender to Death, Doctor
Strange is now actually ageless.
He can still die, but only from being killed
by others.
As far as natural causes are concerned, he’ll
be around after most of us are dust, playing
cards with Thor and Wolverine.
The Sorcerer Supreme vs. Amy Grant
In 1986, Christian singer Amy Grant released
a greatest hits compilation titled The Collection.
Four years later, a Marvel Comics artist decided
Amy Grant could look a lot like a vampire.
The similarity did not go unnoticed, and Amy
Grant's managers brought Marvel Comics to
court.
Their complaint cited the comic's connections
to "witchcraft and the occult," and how associating
Amy Grant with such a comic could do "irreparable
injury" to her reputation among Christian
fans.
The two parties settled 1991, and while we
don't know the terms of the agreement, we
do know one thing.
If you look up the digital version of Doctor
Strange, Sorcerer Supreme #15 today, you’ll
find an empty, red background replacing Amy
Grant's borrowed face.
Too many zeroes
In 2012, The New York Post tried to speak
to Steve Ditko, the creator of Doctor Strange
and co-creator of Spider-Man.
It didn’t work out, mainly because Ditko
is legendarily averse to talking to the media.
He did, however, answer one question: when
they asked if he received any money for any
of the Spider-Man films that had been released
up to that point, he simply said “no.”
But that might not be entirely accurate.
In 2016, Abraham Reisman staked out Steve
Ditko's Manhattan studio, hoping to get a
few words with the reclusive creator.
The best he managed was to get Ditko to answer
his studio door, which Ditko promptly shut
again after shaking his head in what Reisman
describes as "disgust."
He had more luck with other people with offices
in the building, including one unnamed woman
who said she’d mistakenly received a check
meant for Ditko, which she realized wasn’t
hers when it had, quote, “too many zeroes.”
If the story is true, that could mean that
there is some kind of an agreement between
Ditko and Sony or Marvel Studios.
And if it’s not Spider-Man, the most likely
candidate is the Sorcerer Supreme.
Doctor Strange is cool with Doctor Strange
While Steve Ditko may not want anything to
do with film adaptations of his creations,
at least one of his creations feels differently.
In The Unbelievable Gwenpool #3, the title
character makes an appointment with Doctor
Strange.
As a comic book reader from the real world
who found herself transported to the Marvel
Universe, Gwen has no valid Social Security
number or other identifying information to
give her new employer, meaning that she doesn’t
get paid.
While it’s not Strange’s usual problem,
making fake IDs for travelers from another
universe is certainly something he can do.
When Strange peeks into Gwen’s native dimension,
he discovers the relationship between the
real world and his own specifically the film
based on his own comics.
While he might not be thrilled, he definitely
seems okay with the casting choice for the
main character.
The Doctor ROCKS
One of the first things we learn about Stephen
Strange in the 2016 film is that he has an
encyclopedic knowledge of modern music.
But it shouldn't have come as a surprise,
since Doctor Strange has a long history in
the world of rock.
Judging by the covers, the song titles, and
the lyrics, his biggest impact was on Pink
Floyd, who used interior art from Strange
Tales #158 on the cover to their 1968 album
Saucerful of Secrets.
It doesn't stop there.
T. Rex mentioned Doctor Strange in "Mambo
Sun" on the 1971 album Electric Warrior.
In 1965 Jefferson Airplane, The Charlatans,
the Great Society, and others appeared on
a handbill for a concert they called "A Tribute
to Doctor Strange."
The prize for the most elaborate tribute to
the Sorcerer Supreme, though, has to go to
Al Stewart.
The album art for 1974's Past, Present and
the Future and 1975's Modern Times both feature
Doctor Strange, leaping into a portal and
then appearing in a flash of light before
a mansion.
The clothes make the man
In 1968, Doctor Strange took over Strange
Tales as his own comic, but sales began to
slump.
To shake things up, his costume was altered
to a more superheroic look, but the most interesting
detail here isn’t the costume itself it’s
the ridiculous way it was explained.
Doctor Strange #177 opens with Strange and
his lover Clea banished to another dimension
by a villain who mystically disguised himself
in Strange's form.
When Strange attempts to re-enter his own
dimension, an unseen mystical barrier stops
him because there’s already someone there
who looks like him.
That's right: to fool the magical, mystical
boundaries of the universe itself, Doctor
Strange casts a spell that changes his costume
and creates a mask.
Because apparently that’s all it takes.
Maybe he should've just tried glasses?
The Substitute Supreme
Before Marvel's Netflix heroes took the name,
the comic book Defenders were a very different
group with lots...and lots of incarnations.
While the roster would change a dozen times
over the years, Doctor Strange was almost
always part of the team which is pretty ironic
since writer Roy Thomas originally didn’t
want him involved at all.
In a 2013 interview, Thomas said he wanted
the line-up from a story he wrote called “Titans
Three,” with the Hulk, Namor, and the Silver
Surfer.
Unfortunately for Thomas, Stan Lee was very
protective of the Silver Surfer, and hadn't
been thrilled by “Titans Three.”
To match the Surfer’s cosmic power, he suggested
that Thomas use Doctor Strange instead, which
is exactly what he did in Marvel Feature #1.
This time, it seems Lee approved.
Once the Defenders got their own title a few
months later, the Silver Surfer joined the
team in #2.
Galactus?
Pfft.
By the way, Doctor Strange is powerful.
So powerful that even Galactus, the Devourer
of Worlds, is no problem at all.
Well, that might be an exaggeration, but when
the Avengers and Fantastic Four combined forces
against Galactus, Doctor Strange was the one
who turned the tide with a spell that froze
the Devourer in his tracks.
The heroes took the advantage, and once the
smoke cleared, the sorcerer revealed the spell
he cast forced Galactus to confront "the ghosts
of all those he has slain."
Considering Galactus has destroyed entire
worlds, it's easy to see why this particular
tactic was effective.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!